you ever get bitten on on a live show I
was doing a show in San Francisco it was
a show called Mac and Muttley I just
finished teaching a dog how to scuba
dive I do a bunch of shows at the time
so I finished doing that then I finished
doing this I just did a segment on
rhones now I'm doing a segment on snakes
and the bottom line was that I didn't
get a chance to wash my hands under my
own stupidity I went to pick up this
rattlesnake and I have the smell of
rodents on my hands so he launched it
tonight he launched into me and I spent
two days in hospital in San Francisco
and had to take you to know this did you
she almost died I didn't almost die but
I was pretty sick